another big challenge is how to keep
americans safe
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in a brooklyn park that is
taking
an innovative approach david good
morning
good morning to you that is the
manhattan skyline behind me this is
domino park here in brooklyn and there
are 30 white circles on the ground
six feet apart the park officials did
this knowing that last weekend was a
beautiful weekend weather-wise and so
the picture showed people sitting just
as they should have been in their human
parking spots
as someone called it but this is just
what one example of one
what one community is doing to keep
people aware of their proximity to each
other
and you can expect to see more of this
around the country as the nation
continues to reopen
that's it that's new york's governor
andrew cuomo completing his covit 19
test
he's trying to set an example despite a
steady drop in the state's cases for
more than a month now
the governor wants thousands more new
yorkers to get tested for the virus
especially after seeing crowds gathering
in parks over what was a beautiful
weekend here
that is the whole
test i'm not in pain i'm not in
discomfort
closing my eyes was a moment of
relaxation there is no
reason why you should not get the test
okay so it's not a new message but
governors around the country believe it
is one that is necessary
as several states are pushing forward
with their reopening plans despite
spikes in cases
in some places take texas on saturday it
reported the highest
single day increase so far of more than
eighteen hundred cases
seven hundred of those were in amarillo
it was tied to an
increased testing at the city's meat
packing plants
meanwhile defiance of protocols to
remain socially distant
is ongoing across the country in los
angeles where beaches reopen this
weekend
sunbathing is not permitted but that
didn't stop beachgoers
in ohio this was the scene at a bar in
columbus on friday night
the rules for the state are clear for
bars and restaurants
patrons must wear masks and keep a
distance of six feet
governor mike dewine called the photos
here absolutely concerning
candidly you know we've worked with the
attorney general david yost and we're
going to do whatever we have to do if
these things
you know are in fact occur across ohio
in the heartland of america a critical
section of the nation's economic
engine is returning to work today the
big
three major auto manufacturers fiat
chrysler
gm and ford are reopening their auto
plants
that means more than one hundred and
thirty thousand employees
are expected to return to work by the
end of the week sean whitehead
is the director of manufacturing for
ford motor company
we're going to have to be mindful that
we have to really touch base with folks
several times during the course of the
day because life is completely different
than it was in march
and we all have to get used to that
here's what that looks like if you work
for ford
you have to do a health certification
from home if you have even minor
symptoms something like the sniffles
they will probably ask you to stay home
if you go to work they immediately check
you when you walk in things like
temperature checks
and then you've got to wear goggles and
a face shield at work
tony ready or not here we go
david thank you very much